[Music]
[Music]
just the feeling of like
being in a firefight and hearing the
click of the gun throwing it down
grabbing one off the wall
so my gunner's upside down and he's like
laying in i see kill assist kill assist
kill assist
any pistol across any of the games
whatever gun
allows me to feel the most like john
wick i am there
i remember how excited i was with like
this big
combat with vehicles going all over the
place hello means
something there for everyone right i
think that's what makes kayla great
[Music]
[Applause]
what is halo multiplayer and for me it
boils down to
this tight arena style combat
and big team battle this wide open
vehicle infused
kind of combat we're taking that awesome
legacy or classic halo combat experience
and modernizing it in ways that'll feel
fresh to old players and really exciting
to new players
we're going to give you great ways to
customize your spartan really make your
super soldier your own and we're kicking
off
a journey an experience that's going to
evolve month to month
season to season year after year
[Music]
for me working through this multiplayer
of this game and the toughest challenge
i think was really about
how do we respect the legacy of what
came before us but still build something
that feels new
we've tried to bring all these elements
of legacy
and really inject them into halo
infinite not just like in a in
a way where you kind of won't notice it
where you feel like oh they really
designed this to be a celebration
of previous halo as well as an iteration
of where halo can go
[Music]
next
the vision of arena was all about a
tight experience it was all about being
fair
it was all about earning everything on
the map earning everything every kill
you get
going back to like what is the core
foundation of what made
the great halo multiplayer arena matches
great
halo it's really about fair and balanced
starts so everybody's on equal footing
when they come off the rip
and then once they start running around
it's about scavenging it's about finding
new toys
and kind of developing your play style
as you run through the match
what makes halo feel like halo i feel
like
the answer that question is is the
sandbox like the sandbox is halo
when we set out to look at halo infinite
from a high level
and the direction of what it is there's
lots of exciting things there because we
really wanted to push
what are the things that are true to
halo but what are the things that fans
haven't seen yet
equipment is back but equipment is kind
of mo
has the has a bigger voice than ever
before we ask questions to ourselves of
uh if you could go after you know a
power weapon to get a bunch of kills
uh would you do that or could you go and
get grapple to make sure that you
swing yourself to the other side of a
map to back cap a stronghold
we saw it as like another avenue of not
just skill expression but tactics for
teams to coordinate around
the exciting combinatory nature of you
know
this toy plus this toy and how those
interact with objectives is
super amazing looking at how the
power-ups play like your classic
power-ups like the over-shield the
active camouflage
for this title what we're looking at
what we're excited for
is you pick that up and you choose when
you activate it it goes into your
inventory
if you haven't used it and someone kills
you in multiplayer you drop that
overshield and then they can take it use
it for themselves
that to me is very legacy but we took
the equipment side of it and modernized
it
when it comes to the vehicles we went in
and decided to invest a lot in the the
systems
when i take damage to my warthog my
wheels can get blown off
my hood could get blown off there's
different aspects of the vehicle that
change how my vehicle handles now and
that's something that's brand new
another thing we added to that
is like this doom state mechanic so when
you hit this threshold the vehicle
catches fire
and it's very much you've got a certain
amount of health or a certain amount of
time
and you got to choose what you want to
do with the last minutes of this vehicle
we've got a cousin to the warthog which
is the razorback the back has
this like multi-storage compartment that
you can put a lot of stuff into so if
you want to put like
detached turrets power weapons fusion
coils objectives
and that is what really making the
razorback kick a lot of butt
in mp and campaign the levels
define pace for the game how frantic it
is
and they define that iconic fantasy for
players as they're entering that match
what do they want to do
what type of experience are they hoping
to have what kind of combat what kind of
dance floor is they're available to have
that combat in
for me btv is all about experiencing
the full extent of the sandbox of halo
in
just one match right like you see the
vehicles the
weapons the equipment we really wanted
to take that kind of concept those feels
you had you know playing the
playing the previous games and just turn
the volume up
vehicles are no longer just spawning at
bases anymore we have pelicans
delivering them and we have a commander
in your ear telling you
that pelicans are going to be dropping
off these vehicles
we have halo 2 style delta halo mission
weapon pods that fall from the sky to
resupply the field
that's where it makes it feel like like
a real battlefield
and it's very exciting this is not just
more players this is just a
certain beautiful slice of sci-fi chaos
the announcer is your big gameplay
moments your
game modes just like the way it was
before personal ai
is really a reflection and information
for the player
designation so if a player grabs a flag
your personal ai is going to tell you to
you know get that thing back to base
and give you some like moment
moment-to-moment updates
what if we can let players choose their
own ai and each one of those are
different voices
so that players can find the one that
fits their personality and their mood
the best
they add to the sense of like me as a
spartan
being more important and for us in
multiplayer it is really about becoming
a spartan your spartan you are you
inside of the halo universe
the body of customization content that
we have on day one
ensures that there will be millions of
customization combinations for spartans
on the battlefield that includes things
like
armor coatings armor emblems
various armor effects down to the
individual armor pieces so your
shoulders your
gloves your knee pads your helmet your
visor your helmet attachments
then you look at weapons and we've got a
whole slew of customization offerings
there
vehicles have a have a huge pool of
customizations too
we support customization in the game
players can do the same thing on
halowaypoint.com
as well as the halo waypoint app the
player also customizes the spartan the
soldier inside the suit
we want the spartan to represent the
player as much as possible
they can change their body type and
their voice as well as
choose prosthetics for the first time
coatings offer us a unique opportunity
to
craft some hyper-polished looks and let
you express yourselves in ways
you've never been able to before we're
coming at this from a player first
mentality
so what that means is that there's no
random loot in this there's no loot
boxes
it's very important to us that everyone
understands exactly how they unlock
customization content and we have a
variety of places where they can do that
first off is the battle pass the halo
battle pass will never be taken away
from you what i mean by that is once you
buy it it's yours and does not expire
in future seasons you can purchase old
battle passes as well as the current
battle pass and choose
which battle pass to put your
progression towards all of these rewards
are single source
so you're never gonna be confused about
where things come from if you can unlock
something in the battle pass we're not
gonna let any other players circumvent
that by purchasing it out of the
storefront
a lot of our stuff is unlocked through
playing the game and
only through playing the game all
customization is
just cosmetic every season will have its
own theme and introduce
new components new looks new gameplay
for players
new opportunities to earn and collect
cool rewards we've seen the
the samurai already that's one of our
event armor cores
and that's gonna be something that
players can earn through game play
for free with us going free to play for
the multiplayer part of the game like
that was a big goal because you know
how do we have a way we can always bring
players in right and they can
when we have a new update there's
there's they'll just dip their toes in
if they even just want to see it
not only we free to play but we're free
to play on pc
as well as console and what that means
is we're able to get the biggest
audience we've ever had
everybody gets to play with no barriers
and even better your progression
carries from one platform to the next
getting our game to be
on pc and console at the same time is an
amazing
chance for us to really just kind of
excite new players about the game
how can we do things like make
cross-play interesting and like even in
just customs being able to just play
with your friends
like some people have pcs and some
people have consoles and like let them
talk to each other let them be friends
why are you here to be a spartan
academy is a place that you can go with
an mp
to kind of onboard into the experience
it's great for
newer players who are still picking up
the controls and also people who
want to warm up before they head into
matchmaking it's a series of experiences
both a tutorial to get started for the
first time weapon drills to practice
with specific items
and also training mode that you can use
to just
get warm explore the game as you want to
for players who are new to halo
let's help them learn what this universe
is about some of these characters what
are they about
and help them kind of know the
vocabulary that people have been
speaking for now
almost 20 years so that when they come
in there they don't feel like they're
behind everyone else
they can kind of come in on an even
footing i mean i'm super jazzed about
bots
i think they're awesome our goal with
bots has been to
have a variety of difficulties that kind
of
provide a good training partner for
wherever you're at in the experience
partnering with our players on the road
to launch
and after launch is absolutely critical
right i mean halo's always been about
the community
conversation we want to make sure we
hear our players make changes
where we can based on that feedback make
sure the game is ready for
launch and then even beyond launch what
i'm genuinely excited about
is taking the game out of our hands and
putting it into the community's hands
you know whether it's seeing what people
make in forge or the content that
they're able to create with theater
watching streamers go after the game to
get involved you go to
haloinsider.com put in your info with
your gamer tag
and we should be able to reach out to
you if we want to invite you to a halo
infinite flight
we feel like we've got a pretty good
selection at launch and what's going to
be there for our fans
and this isn't going to be something
that is just a static set of
items we have some new stuff in the
works already
and just can't wait to really get into
that as
soon as this game comes out new maps new
modes new ways to customize your spartan
launch is just the beginning now we're
just going to be able to talk
interact more frequently and that's just
going to be great that is the future of
halo infinite multiplayer thank you to
the community for all their feedback
over the years so far
and i'm looking forward to the road 2
launch launch
itself and beyond
[Music]
so
[Music]
play it day one with xbox game pass